this is a production of Cornell
University
it's real honored to be here and a
pleasure guys this is kindly coming to
the heart of what this whole program is
about I'm a hydro ecologist I worked in
wetlands for almost all my life until
about seven years ago I was put in what
was said was a desert I'm thinking oh
I'm used to water so learning a lot
about agriculture watering agricultural
systems and so we have lots of questions
in our and I thought today you know I
think I'm gonna give an overview of the
whole thing my goal is that it will
stimulate discussion and maybe different
pieces will appeal to different people
and we have lots of lots of skill to do
lots of things we're trying to learn and
if you know something about it hear me
say something that doesn't make sense or
you know something different we're
trying to learn about it so feel free to
email me or call me or talk and say I
want to talk to you about that piece so
what you're hearing today is kind of an
overview of the whole program okay I
want to think there's a lot of people in
this probably the most important one is
this woman direct Alicia and she's
actually the head of the names of
Forestry institutes the director of the
laboratory of seedling bioengineering
she's so influential that she's the one
they asked the governor of ningxia
province which is like the equivalent of
a state we need to restore this area
you're in charge they put her in
Congress for China she's that
influential and she's been a big
motivating force dr. Sheng Shanley at
Southwest University in Chongqing is
actually responsible for restoration of
the Three Gorges reservoir at the entire
riparian area around there this here is
a Humphrey Solo back in like 2008 he's
one who brought Cornell over and said
these people can help us Steve where he
always over in our department I'll
mention some of the work he does but
he's been my partner the enormous all
this going back and forth to China
Harold's been influential from the
beginning and guiding us and a lot of
people how do you see your names up
there we've come to talk to you about
what we're doing
you've given us advice out of you we're
really good about being collaborators on
proposals and supporting us so there's a
lot of people who have helped in
different ways and it's much appreciated
and hopefully we keep we'll keep
building this program all right so what
I'm gonna do is give you part about
what's the framework for what this whole
project is about it's kind of what we've
come to understand this
about agriculture in the world which is
what you guys do feedback welcome and
then with that context was also got what
we've been doing endings for China we
started moving into the Great Plains and
Mandan North Dakota and then we have
some new directions for going so as I
said there's a lot of pieces to this and
hopefully I'll keep you with me
throughout all right the big issue is
this one of how to feed the population
of the world basically we have nine
billion people by the year 2050 and we
have to close a nearly 70 percent gap
between how much we currently produce
and how much we're going to need to
produce I do water so I'm always focused
on the water part and the reality is all
the water we consume around the world
70% of it goes to use for irrigation to
grow food so this is really to be
initial of water currently about 2.2
thousand eight hundred cubic kilometers
of water consumed each year just for
irrigation only a quarter of our crop
lands are irrigated and that delivers
one third of our agricultural production
so one solution to the food problem is
AG intensification we will increase our
yields through more irrigation more
fertilization but the reality I do water
is that we are already waters arguably
wet the most scarce limiting resource on
the earth it's not energy and I'll fight
I'll argue that a lot there are all
different kinds of analyses of how many
people are subject to global waters to
water scarcity it was always done on an
annual basis and about the approximate
number was about both 25 percent of all
the world's population deals with some
level of water scarcity and then in 2016
the study came out well actually if you
just look at one on a monthly basis four
billion people have water scarcity I
mean they don't have enough water and
get any given month and so it's really
almost half the world's population deals
with water scarcity and up here where we
throw away fresh water we it rained so
much we get rid of it it's kinda like
wow we don't really pay attention how
important this issue is all this has
been exacerbated by climate change
because it's changing where how often
and how much rainfall we get and so this
is just one of the model predictions for
changes in certifications around the
world and what
Stanground as it gets browner that means
you have fewer and fewer inches of rain
per year and that's what we saw like the
big drought in California and in large
parts the world less water to work with
so that issue is let's increase
irrigation to me is like guys that is
not a good solution we need water for
people to drink we need water for all
the other uses we have for water
the second big factor is soil
degradation and so again this is now
getting to your realm that's why I'm
pleased to be here and that land
aggregated this was an estimate in 2017
land degradation has made it to about
1/4 of all the global land area and
there are different maps showing high
severity very high severity so large
portions of the land are really degraded
which affects their ability to produce
crops
and once you have unhealthy soil then he
actually need more water to get the same
amount of crops and this is a photo just
show you what we saw you in nature China
where every single thing you see if you
see something run it's got a drip
irrigation too it's either coming from
ground water which is very scarce they
don't monitor it or it's coming from the
Yale River which also runs dry and
location so it's very I mean everything
has to be irrigated all right
the agriculture to grow the food IQ PI's
basically 40% of all the land service of
the earth either as cropland or as
pastures and there's that whole issue of
well we could have eaten meat we can
shift this over to growing crops and
it's much more efficient and that's one
of the solutions when you look at all
what are the solutions to deal with
needing to produce food however there's
this cool fact and this was the epiphany
for me as I was learning about this
system it came out in a 2013 report by
the Union Nations environmental program
addressing these issues of how do we
grow enough food and what they did is
looked at all the land surface of the
earth and said well okay 5,000 million
hectares or just deserts glaciers others
3,900 or forests but where we have
permanent pastures and arable in all of
that was grassley where we put all of
our agriculture which and almost night
like 95% of it used to be grasslands and
that was really interesting so when you
start to think well grasslands huh
there are lots of like a lots been gonna
grasslands but interestingly they
basically kind of generally came into
three categories savannas prairies or
steps even the Great Plains of the
United States that we tend to call
prairies actually now in some places are
calling it a step and so do you think it
well if it's a third of the land surface
of the earth you think there'd be a
little bit more diversity to it than
just three types of grasslands and right
now
nature serve T and C are definitely
starting to say well that is true I mean
there's a lot of different kinds of
grasslands they're not all the same and
then we're getting to understand them
better okay
but the key point is that grasslands
where we put our agriculture developed
in areas that are semi arid or arid all
right less than five hundred millimeters
of rainfall year they're naturally
evolved to deal with semi arid
conditions
okay so Whitaker put out a long time ago
the biomes of the world here's
grasslands and basically in this
moderate temperature range but low
precipitation progresses and they were
incredibly productive historically this
is where he had this incredible all
these different bison bison in above
it's all these different migrations and
below-ground had all this productivity
is well these are millions and the
millions of animals and blue ground
there's all like tons of different
species of rodents and prairie dogs and
then there were birds and insects and
here's this incredibly productive first
it's um different levels of the food web
right all living in a system that was
very air eating it now this is where we
put our agriculture and we're having
trouble growing things you think what
what have we done to that system that's
made it now not be able to support what
it used to support even we're gonna do
I'm going to be showing you what we're
doing in temperate grasslands I don't
quite and one of the reasons like I
don't know what's going on with tropical
grasslands I don't quite get it because
we're gonna be talking about most all
organic soils that form but in like
Africa they have some of the highest
species diversity of mammals
particularly bovids which are horn
animals that are have hollow horns they
don't drop off incredible species
diversity that meant that those
grasslands were stable long-term
environments
that kind of speciation to occur I don't
know what the mechanisms are that
maintain those systems in terms of
moisture but we're going to talk about
the temperate ones nonetheless here's
the thing all this product committee in
semi-arid conditions one factor in the
temperate systems where these moments
all soils enter you guys which were deep
organic soils that form because the
grasses with decaying roots decaying
leaves that would build up in the soil
and have this organic matter that was
basically like a cellulose sponge is the
way I like to think of it or I explain
to people you know they used by your
sink it absorbs and holds water and so
much of the United States the green here
are the Mullis all soils up there
there's a whole bunch down in South
America large parts of Asia had these
soils that were a factor in a semi-arid
climate that when it rained it could
hold that moisture alright so when you
look at this is the most well-documented
case that we can find which are the
great plains of the United States where
mussels being 60 to 75 75 or more
percent of US soil is a Mullis all soil
throughout the central the dark colors
which is right where our tall grass
mixed grass short grass prairies mainly
days there occurred that's those were
our mon-sol soils and then John Deere
1837 so this is again you guys know it
was stuff but for me you know I live up
in transferred this farm fields there's
green tractors everywhere I look to say
John Deere and I think you know there's
this guy out there somewhere oh he
invented the stainless steel plow that
was the first thing that could actually
break through the grassland sods and
10,000 of these were sold by 1855 and
that's what allowed agriculture to
develop in our country so 1855 we began
to break apart the grasslands the soils
and then we began to erode away and then
in other places that was livestock over
grazing but basically what I can tell
the surface most all soil began to
disappear and the it's well documented
there was the Dust Bowl in the Great
Plains and it was actually black sundy
because that was the black organic
matter blowing across the landscape and
there
all these no very iconic photograph
showing loss of little surface organic
layer 16 million acres destroyed in
Texas by erosion terrace to protect your
farm and it was beginning from what I
can tell the NRCS and their whole kind
of health program soil health program in
the United States but so as we think
about well what was the original soil
like it's not that easy to find out
so NRCS start I can get access to maybe
I'm monitoring erosion and there's all
these different maps from 1982
I don't read like two to four year
intervals and so this is 1982 1987 90 to
97 2002 these are the rates of erosion
per region and when you add them all up
it was about 180 tons per acre of
erosion and I don't give me this great
photo but we can find other photos and
the question is yeah but that was
already in 1982 black sunday was like
1933 and plows were in 1855 doesn't
serve almost a hundred more years of
erosion that wasn't documented what did
the soil look like what are these soils
that were so productive that could
support so much life what do they look
like that's the one that is
well-documented agriculture has been
going on apparently for thousands of
years
so if you go to Crete at Greece and this
is actually where I was reading this
book in Greece right before we went to
China and it's like oh create used to be
covered in soothing shade trees it was
all gone it was a barren soil and the
only vegetation left was called a fruit
for ganya a soul incapable of holding
moisture only plants left for aromatic
drought-tolerant shrubs and go to it
neat and all the trees have been and
then you can read about it taken away
either to build chips where around most
of the world articulated as a fuel for
heating work for cooking you don't ever
leave wood behind and gradually what it
looks like it's a barren landscape okay
and that was in 425 right now and the
pampas of Argentina a lot of native
grasslands are still intact the
conversion is happening again
in this case is Nev cattle ranching and
erosion problems are happening and
that's like in less than 30 years and so
there's this kind of timeline of the
further you go back it looks more and
more thinner and eroded and so you end
up with these maps of global soil
degradation and rekon Lao out in Ohio
has been doing estimates since the 1990s
look guys we have to plead a global
organic carbon stocks by as much as 66
Hika grams no I don't know that's right
seventy two billion US tonnes a
phenomenal amount of her organic matter
we have eroded away all right so that's
the background that as I understand it
that this kind of erosion loss has been
going on on what was one-third of the
land surface of the earth because it was
converted to agriculture but it used to
be incredibly productive in the case of
the temperate areas that was a Mullis
all soil I don't know what the souls
wearing tropical grassland I hate trying
to kind of learn about that but we're
focused here right now so now we go to
China and this is China here's Mongolia
and it's this is newly desertified this
is seriously the most seriously degraded
lands are desertified abandoned and the
hatching is where this is occurring and
that's in the Google image we're working
right here and here's the gobi desert
mongolia Taklamakan and you can see and
this is actually the Yellow River so
there's a big river that runs through
there but the areas seriously
desertified so we're working right here
in toin and there's Beijing over there
Mongolia is just north of us just to see
here's this beautiful river running
through but most of the landscape looks
like this and literally a Olien dunes
blowing sand but when we were there it
rained and then it rained again about a
week later
that's like wait a minute this is not a
desert you have rainfall why what's
going on why don't you have something
growing here and we began to realize oh
this is agriculture since almost at
least a thousand to 2,000 years ago
this is the landscape now but when we
went to a museum there were petroglyphs
of grassland animals on the rocks and it
became like this used to be a grassland
you still have rain and we said well
where's the organic matter and we spent
an interesting couple days driving
around trying to get them to show us
where there was some organic matter and
we couldn't get couldn't we had a real
communication I didn't know what we were
talking about oh well we take all that
away use that to cook with you use it to
heat with it it's messy you don't leave
that on the ground it took us a week
almost define the tiniest little layer
of organic matter building up and say oh
this has been so degraded you've lost
track of what that was and what its role
was so the our project became what wait
a minute and there were a lot of pieces
else and as well but this is the one
note we've really focused on almost well
can you read vitalize this system can we
restore that grassland is there some way
to jumpstart the whole system so just
waiting for it to slowly recover and
we're going to use amendments will try
and jumpstart the system to a better
level and then can we help increase
their adoption either healthier crop
lands that don't require a lot of
irrigation or self-sustaining grassland
so that was kind of our goal and so the
underlying question you're gonna see
this continues throughout this issue
what they didn't quite know what we were
talking about keeps showing up above
what's the goal ideal goal to me as an
ecologist is what we want that nice
healthy grassland bag with all those
animals and all that productivity then
it's but can we even figure out what
that was given getting data is pretty
hard and then what's a feasible target I
mean what's your realistic maybe we
don't mean restoration maybe we mean
revitalization or enhancement maybe we
really need to think carefully about
what these words mean and then what are
the elements and I think of it as a
recipe the ingredients of the recipes
that we're going to use to achieve that
target so soil amendments this is your
guys world being used for thousands of
years from manure all kinds of things
and they either get mixed into the soil
or they get put on top of the soil and
mulch and compost manures organic matter
and fine and coarse woody material and
we chose to use coarse woody material
from the beginning because we said well
we need this stuff to be there for a
long time if I put in iceberg lettuce
it's gone and a week
I need organic matter that's gonna stick
around a while and we said we'll go with
coarser material and we also said we're
gonna look at something different a
different pieces we really get branches
where we apply not just mixing it into
the soil but we're gonna get surface
applications so the steam or ele who is
a zoologist and which has been studying
for 10 years the effective first
practices on amphibians reptiles animals
near here done it are not because now
they're clearing when they take out
vegetate trees and all they take every
branch it's worth something you can
grind it up and make particle board so
they were looking for evidence well you
kind of need these piles of branches and
they have all these different date on
what animals use them as refugia and
germination and tree growth and deer
can't get to them but the relevant one
was that they looked at water content of
the soil and these are different sites
and they looked at sites ahead Apollo
franchise in bare soil and consistently
had more water retained in the soil over
time when the branches were present and
that was our goal
we want more water to stay there so the
very first thing we did was a simple
experiment the honor student Cornell's
honors undergraduate basically a master
students other places we have amazing
students and it was a very simple one
before we went back to China we said
we've got to make sure this is gonna
work he used a very sandy soil it was an
artificial constructed one we can't
bring the soles over from China and all
we did was mix in varying amounts of
organic matter of woodchips of populist
I'm you Louise trembling Aspen zero it's
a control two percent four percent ten
percent on a wafer weight basis we tried
different species populous black locust
willow cattails these are all present
over where we are in Asia by which are
and then we put surface twigs as kind of
a proxy for having branches over the
surface at five replicates
put 100 milliliters on top and then
weighed it every day
so what you see is these are the days
after Wooters ad at one time how much of
that hundred mils is still left percent
what are we meaning the black line on
the bottom is the control
so obviously water is evaporating
there's less water remaining with time
and each of these lines represents the
average of one of those treatments all
the way up to we're going to focus on
populous for today so here is 4%
populous and after two weeks we had 18
more 18 percent more water in the soil
that hadn't evaporated and if we added
the litter ones how we could get a few
more percent water remaining so we
reduced evaporation by adding wood chips
to the soil we had more water for longer
up to a month we still were having the
same kind of retention in the system and
all it did was control evaporation
we use that as the basis for going to
China and why don't we had two
technicians working there who then the
first one she gone turned this into his
PhD thesis repeated the experiment
butting kind of ultra and so here's our
control this is the actual soil over
there it's 90 about 99% sand that
organic matter the twigs on the top is
the equivalent to the lattice of
branches
we tried mulch here's 2 5 8 increasing
amounts of populous they have populous
alba a different one it's planted over
all of China this is a different for
different species of wood different tree
species minore rice and wheat and so
that's all the different treatments with
five replicates each looked at a whole
bunch of things infiltration rate
microbial respiration soil capillarity
pore space he looked at um so bunch of
things the point being that was a set up
very similar to what we just did he
weighed them and I put here infiltration
rate instead of all the other data
because right away it was affecting one
another property another process this is
control and twigs with his up on top
since I control soil and any kind of
amendment addition reduced infiltration
so there was less water leaching out of
the system
that's so we have another mechanism
somehow alright pause it for six so for
me this was like a no-brainer
Oh wood absorbs water you put what in
the soil it rains and holds the water
slowly releases it turns out people are
really questioning the mechanisms here
and so we're putting more time to like
trying to understand what are the
precise mechanisms if you think about it
when I have branches on top of the
surface it shades so that reduces heat
right it also affects the boundary layer
so therefore evaporations reduce that's
a different mechanism the wood chips in
the soil apparently we think breaking up
the flow paths so the waters ability to
evaporate is interfered with we haven't
tested my idea that and water is just
absorbing the wood is of blurring water
but there's now a whole complex of
mechanisms that may be inner all acting
together Rebecca yeah how was the water
actually applying
in the experiment the first experiments
literally 100 million years is a closed
container and was in 25 mil increments
slowly at the very beginning of the
evaporation experiment I know right
right at the surface supported okay as I
said we also are interested well what's
happening below the sort in terms of
life and so in that this was your gods
thesis and in that very complex
experiment he also halfway through at
its seeds to the weed seeds and show
that he could and they and we could
affect how much growth here was a week
by adding amendments to it you could
affect how much wheat growth we got okay
right the first experiment was applied
one time just 100 mils one time and it
ran for a month about four and a half
five weeks total this one is a little
more complicated
he added at regular intervals at once he
added the week to the system
it's a hold on exactly how much water he
added so it's more complicated and then
we took that and said all right well
let's look what's happening in the
chemists work in the field those are
just Rican sold experiments and we set
up in ningxia this is the system we're
working in everything back here is
irrigated with a drip tube we had four
treatments I'll show you what they were
five replicates of each we had one suite
that was not irrigated at all and one
that was and we set that up originally
because it rained so little with it
we'll have it never rains we'll have new
data will irrigate one half of it and
their word so there were forty plots and
how it was very helpful in getting the
design of this set of course so here's
the control soil the unamended soil here
it is with woodchips of populist album
mixed in to the top twenty centimeters
of the soil of five percent by volume
this is the chips plus this lattice of
branches it was about thirty percent
cover so you can see light throughout
hitting the surface and then we had a
surface mulch application all right this
is temperature over one growing season
so that was one of the original things
we saw in the are not forest work and
basically here are the controls in black
hitting above 40 degrees centigrade
we had chips then service mulch and the
chips plus the branches could reduce the
overall temperatures by almost 20
degrees so we could definitely keep the
system cooler obviously when you have
amendment on the surface it helped but
even just having chips in the soil
reduce the temperature it also was good
did what we hoped it would do it helped
to maintain up to capture more water so
this is the rain event this is the
control this is the chips plus the
branches over top this is chips
this is mulch and the rain event occurs
it captures more rain and then it stays
moisture for longer that's just one
event this is in 2012 and then we have
the same class for 2015 four years later
which looked pretty similar this is so
water storage over time so here's the
control here's the branches plus the
chips underground in this case this is
the chips and this is the mulch
sometimes the Walsh did better sometimes
the chips did better branches plus the
chips always did way better so basically
over the course of a whole summer and
then four years later we haven't changed
anything we still have the same
improvements in the system to capture
and hold water okay we were agent this
had 150 millimeters of rainfall these
are tiny amounts of rainfall over the
course of this growing season and so we
said well wait a minute is this normal
it's just what you normally get so we
looked at 15 year record and found what
the average amount of rainfall was and
then we looked at well how old as I come
in it comes in as 21 events all rain
events that last for about 1 and a half
days very small amounts 8 millimeters
and the key is how many days before the
next rain event it was 4 days if we only
consider rains bigger than 1 millimeter
drop the number of events and increase
it to 5 point 6 so basically it's tiny
amounts of rain but it comes at every 4
to 5 days now why that's important we're
trying to think well how do you
translate that does does this make a
difference so we calculated what the
permanent wilting point was for the
system using a very conservative
estimate said in each of those
these were all irrigated these are not
this is 2012 and 2015 for the controls
and so we're basically the days and
justice out on that sediment that's Andy
soil you have 50 between 30 and 50 days
where the soils below the permanent
wilting point with that rainfall pattern
in those irrigated situation which got
more water all the amendments helped us
to reduce irrigation demand the number
of days below permit wilting point as
compared to controls so it would make a
difference if you put chips in the soil
you can reduce the irrigation to that
and the non irrigated where now no it's
just the rainfall pattern it didn't make
a difference with just the chips but
both launched there was only four reps
here there are five reps there but both
the mulch and the chips plus the mulch
are significantly different we could
definitely reduce under non irrigated
conditions the number of days and these
are I mean is it really dry guys 170
millimeters so we're talking sixty days
where it's below the permanent wilting
point but still we can make it better a
bunch of other things were measured
including soil microbial respiration we
have enzyme activity so carbon microbial
carbon microbial nitrogen but basically
what you see is the control and mulch
mulch does a really good job at keeping
it moist but underneath the soil bulk
density hasn't changed the bacterial
don't grow and so adding the tips
actually increase the life in the soil
it's the way we like to think wherever
we have wood in the soil and at both
experiment and in the field we're
increasing the whole system's kind of
living functioning below ground so so
much so that in 2013 in the middle of
the summer we had moss and mushrooms
growing in the branch wall the branch
chip treatment so it's mostly a
mushrooms in the middle of the desert
and in 2016 it was awesome
we were working and under a couple of
pounds Rita what are those things and
turns out they're long eared hedgehogs
families living back in the middle of
that dry desert II area and they had set
up homes underneath those systems and so
overall it's a healthier more living
system
a lot we don't know but things are
working better okay it's been difficult
we're in China we can't bring souls back
all the money we have is really coming
from the Chinese government made it hard
to do experiments here so we said we
need to find something we can work in
the US the northern Great Plains
Research Laboratory which is one of the
longest now it's an LTE rll t8y our it
has about a hundred years of data for an
agricultural station it's located right
here and Herald recommended talking to
dr. mark riebeck who say yeah come you
can work with us and it's in the mix big
grass prairie in North Dakota and what's
totally cool about this is that the
climate in North Dakota is almost
exactly what we get in nature China in
terms of both the temperature Mandan
North Dakota is in blue with a high and
low for each month
the yellow is China Ningxia China and
they're very comparable both in
temperature and precipitation patterns
but they don't irrigate and they do so
the soils are really different I mean we
have 93 percent sand very little organic
matter high pH different texture but
still we now have the same climate it's
what can we do to that soil to make it
more similar to this to make it a
healthier system so we're trying to
revitalize this system we actually did
an experiment they're the same one we
said well here's no amendment in these
are called caliper shell sandy loam
soils here we added chips to the soil
ratios plus chips did this in 2015 over
the course of the summer biometric water
content we used to decagon probes those
are the rain events and what you see is
these are the average out for each
treatment this is the control soil
moisture content this is when we added
chips to it and here's the branch plus
chips and our colleagues they were very
surprised they thought they didn't
really expect it they go really we
didn't think this would make any
difference at all that we could actually
improve the system now they don't
irrigate what Mark said is well actually
our soils are like on the edge if we
keep you up with the same practices we
have right now we won't have more
erosion but if they changed what we grow
we change the practices we're going to
start looking like the west and south of
here
going Weston's house this would be
really important but we don't need to
irrigate still it wasn't really
insightful to know that oh you can even
improve what we're doing in that region
right there and then because we had
access to the soils we started asking
some other questions too so Aaron
Menzies who's a doctoral student working
with hi Walter in US and ve started
looking she's very interested in
nutrient pollution and used the tally
per shell soils as the basis to say well
what happens to like if we want to
fertilize can the woodchips affect how
much nutrients leach out of this system
and she did an experiment and she looked
at liquid fertilizers dry fertilizers
incorporated service or fertilizers and
compared with no chips with chips and
how much nitrogen and phosphorus leach
out of the system giving the chips
what's the role so that's her kind of
the basis for her thesis and she's also
really starting to look into this issue
of what's the mechanism so they've come
up with a really clever idea of using
rubber mulch which i think it's like
disgusting but you can buy it although i
get egg weigh bags and rubber mulch from
tires but it's basically it's wood chips
only its rubber chips so they don't
absorb water so we're gonna do some
experiments using rubber chips versus
wood chips I'm trying get a better hand
on what these mechanisms are and that's
what she's doing as part of her
dissertation ok so that's kind of the
core program of what we've been doing
but there's these other pieces to it all
right one and this is what I said the
benefits of an ecological perspective
it's
when we're over there every morning
there's condensation due when all the
cars we're probably I don't know several
miles away from the Yellow River and
this is a desert guys and we said well
wait a minute if there's condensation
everybody reports water availability has
inches of rain centimeters of rain but
maybe this can make a difference so we
did an experiment growing three kinds of
grass prairie grasses under controlled
conditions we're weighing them at night
weighing them in the morning seeing how
much water condensed putting lintel and
so they couldn't convince any water and
basically again I'm giving you a very
short synopsis of things through
condensation each night the grass is
captured 23% up to one case 46% of the
water they lost in daily transpiration
we also showed in a different small
study that they reduce the evaporative
loss at night that's really important
when you're talking 170 hundred eighty
millimeters a year you know in the
growing season being able to capture
water through do is really key now grass
is the most exciting part to me grasses
are really cool cuz they're all these
comp dense stems they're perfectly if
you think that's like a forest of stems
which you Wow how do they
photosynthesize no the point is they can
capture water it can run down it doesn't
evaporate they're evolved to capture you
we don't even think about that that
means if you don't have a grassland
you've lost a key mechanism that wasn't
critical to the system's ability to
capture and hold moisture it means you
really got to think about what you're
gonna grow if you restore that system
and so as an ecologist at guys we got to
get grasses growing back in there we're
doing some work with what species in
northern China Agra piranha Mungo Lakota
I'm learning grasses but we can
definitely improve grass growth there's
difficulties getting them started but
once we get them up and running we can
get more breasts to grow all right a
second area and and this is me I've been
arguing this one all along and I'll keep
going is it's about the ingredients of
the recipe what do you put in it and
right now it's coarse woodchips a little
bit of fertilizer that's a lot of work
that Jaedong did me to fertilizer the
pure sands doesn't have anything in them
but I am arguing well guys we can put
all this stuff in and so recently
there's been a lot
attention on the fact that wood
decomposes at different rates so if you
think about it it's like I say iceberg
lettuce disappears in a week but one's
really vary and so we used populist
remedies Aspen that 50% corn the k.k
rates about one to two years we
definitely noticed by 2015 we were
losing our wood was disappearing this
wood chips and experimenting either
needs to be right your vital eyes but we
don't have quite what we had but there
are bunches the species that decompose
very slowly black locust is the one I'm
familiar with farmers will tell you when
I put fence posts in put in black locust
it'll last for 80 years it doesn't think
so what happens if we used that would
what could it do in our restoration
recipe this issue of carbon
sequestration is key for mitigating
climate change Ratan Lau and a bunch of
people have put out estimates of where
can we do use grasslands as a key for
rest for dealing with carbon and so
restoration is a piece of it people
haven't done much with it we argue well
you could put black locust into the
recipe we had an undergrad honor student
Mary Ellen Garcia one of your guys you
might more she was great and we did some
simple static alkali chambers quantified
co2 production from control we used to
tally precious oil with the with out
populous chips and with without locust
chips and for sure and then we had a
whole bunch of different treatments but
this one had nitrogen fertilizer
attitude but basically locust same
amount decomposed put out less co2 then
the populace and so we are you you can
add locusts to the recipe and we can
sequester carbon how much so a 10% vind
a volume amendment would give you 1.7
kilograms of carbon for each square
meter point two meters deep at seventeen
thousand kilograms per hectare of carbon
sequestered it would take you 20 trees
50 cent 15 centimeters tbh it's not that
big a deal it's not that much
i I'm convinced over this areas we're
talking about we could do a credible
amount of carbon sequestration that'll
sit there for a long time the third
piece started two summers ago mainly
because the change
and said well what would this do for
saline soils and we were kind of
overwhelmed but okay let's see what we
can come up with and we said all right
we'll do a test of the wood chips and
we're gonna because this if they're flat
all that salts accumulating has to be
irrigated but we'll put it in a ridge
and furrow system with irrigation along
the top put wood chips in it this is
what the soils look like these guys we
work with these work big so there's
about 10 acres of this set up these are
the ridge this is the drip irrigation
tube this is the woodchips that's what
it looked like and we went back and
there was with no amendment and they
were starting things up there
this is goji berry as a endemic as
native to this area and so there's what
it looks like in the salty soil even
with drip irrigation and this is what it
looks like in five months they had a
complete crop of sunflowers and goji
berry it's a shrub so it took a bit a
little bit longer so it's like oh now we
don't know if it's diluting the salt we
don't know it's bonding to the salt with
through cation exchange capacity you
don't know the mechanisms
there's tons of more questions that have
to be asked but it definitely suddenly
took this land now it's using the
irrigation which I'm trying not to do
that but still they need to feed people
and so suddenly this land that was
totally unusable it's now being put into
production so where we are right now the
most recent work it's back at that
original issue of what's the goal and
how do you get there
and so I was like enough working with
Harold and then Kerstin and there's this
whole your whole new initiators to look
at soil holistically and like for
farmers not just well what's your
nutrient status NPK here add some
fertilizer but you how healthy is the
soil and it's taken across the world
it's using this this is the way we're
going it was a holistic look at all
different properties active carbon all
different ways of thinking about the
looking at the soil and we said well
that's perfect it gives us a diagnostic
tool to look at a degraded grass on Sol
and say what's there and then what does
it need and so we're saying oh we're
going to use that as this the basis of
the assessment and diagnosis of these
degraded soils and
then help us to determine the recipe so
we went to that we're starting in the
tall grass prairies which are the
richest wettest of what I could tell
mullah Sol's the ones that are in the
greatest shape everything on West gets
drier gets a little bit more confusing
this should be the best and a Kirsten
has joined the graduate program my
department and working with us right now
she's a master student and we went out
this fall and collect in August and
collected soils from Relic prairies and
in an adjacent field agricultural field
as a comparison we have about 300
samples from five different pairs and a
couple of interesting take-home message
and so that's what she'll be doing it's
the basis of her master's doing the soil
health analysis holistically and then
saying okay we know what it is it'll be
interesting to see what how it compares
to the AG what would we do to restore
this and then we're going to go west and
start looking at like in North Dakota
and further but one of the interesting
things came out of this was um one it
wasn't so easy to find like virgin
Prairie now they may still be there but
what we found as little remnants in the
back of somebody's farm who didn't want
to it wasn't good enough to grow things
on there were a few that were being
preserved but they were still actually
not they were still hanging them or
having livestock use them even in
preserve and it came down to well
they're not really virgin
they weren't tilled as far as anybody
can remember that's what I've come up
with what's available out there hasn't
been tilled in our memory that's the
definition and so it's kind of this
issue of well what what's the ideal
what's the what did they used to look
like we did a kind of informal census
just for fun and talking to people you
know a restaurants hey you know this is
tall grass prairies best souls in the
world and how many would a prairie or
grassland was and curse it was like six
of nine did not even know what those
words meant and they were in when you're
there all you see is cornfield a few
Slough that's it for you know hundreds
of miles were driving it's like oh my
god this is nothing but cornfield and
they had forgotten they didn't even know
anything Wow even the scientists don't
we work with don't really
Oh what these should look like and so
what the ideal I mean this may be the
best we get for what an idealist we're
gonna go again in the spring and sample
more North and North Dakota and South
Dakota of tall grass prairies it'll be
interesting to see maybe this is the
best that currently exists but it's not
what it used to be you don't know we've
gotten some publications out we're
finally getting those out we've had some
real good achievements we gave it round
a special session at the snow Science
Society list
2016 we've been cut designated as the
flagship project by China for this USDA
the most program we put in and once you
actually agreed to collaborate for this
global hundred million dollar global
challenge last year we made the top 200
honorable mention think it's Hungarian
and we were listed as one of the top
three most collaborative programs
between the United States and China so
we have we feel good about it there's so
much we don't know don't understand but
it shows great promise it's parts of it
work really well so I'm open to
questions and again I'm hoping I'm
stimulating I mean maybe you all know
all this you know maybe it's you know
I'm coming from a different direction
but hopefully if you think of things you
want to talk about email me any thoughts
even the whole interpretation of that
epiphany for me that whole world used to
be grasslands and it's all AG that's all
degraded what the heck happened you know
that I mean maybe teach this in 101 I
don't know so thank you very much
[Applause]
yeah micro grab the nitrogen that you
can pose which it's wondering how that
works okay so interestingly our first
paper we put together a literal one
there's not that many studies that I've
actually looked at would in soil it's a
lot of times they'll call me Ben green
compost where and it's a mixture of
things not well designated and they've
seen conflicting results about whether
you get nitrogen amylose immobilization
in the soil in the experiment you're
going did we saw nitrogen drop we did
but it's not clear-cut that it always
happens in the literature it maybe
that's why for the recipe you're gonna
have to add a little fertilizer we don't
know that but it's we're adding very so
in that issue when I'm done the review
see it iron ratio varies let's say one
to 21 to 15 one to 10 for woods
it's all dust in the four papers I read
is one to five five hundred to one
carbon and nitrogen five hundred to one
from told us why I don't even get it so
species really different we're trying to
understand why does Locust take 80 years
to compose maybe you're not going to get
nitrogen immobilization it's a slow
decomposing would maybe IRAs are so
coarse that actually the the bacteria
function is slowed down I don't know but
it's not as clear-cut as people think
when you're working with coarse wood
from what I can tell from the literature
but believe me I'm paying close
attention we're trying to and if anybody
gets why I sold us is five hundred to
one I mean you know they do these states
where they add sugar to see if
respiration increases will put in
sawdust that's five hundred to one I
don't like what kind of salt what are
you using you know what is that I don't
know
sawdust is mostly you know mostly yeah I
know but even still when I look at the
literature from xylem versus the other
parts of the bark it's not five hundred
to one you know I don't know whether the
fine scale of it and they're actually
getting backed I don't know but that's
what you know the literature we put it
together that's what I got out of
literature but the CDN immobilization
issue is on the table it's something we
have to think about okay right that is
the question everybody keeps saying oh
all right so in China about 20 years ago
they because of erosion they set up a
program of planting trees across all the
roads it's all populist Alaba it may be
one individual problems have everywhere
so working with this variants eventual
person we said look just give us every
third tree and grow something else and
it's all on the highway they're easily
cut you can cut it bring it and so
there's a lot of wood available and it
needs to be diversified for a bunch of
setting you know vulnerability and also
we have access to that like coming out
here there's hardwoods along creek beds
and all but I ultimately you might have
to grow for me black locust row at near
the farm fields but it's a sequestering
carbon while you do it you can actually
copy sit and the same with the poppies
you can cut it keep it growing and have
a source but for me people Oh nobody
would do that that would cost so much
money bring it in on trucks the reality
is like they put a bridge in the air
house that has 20 homes there are two
other roads people can take and one
other bridge it cost some two million
dollars for one bridge to 20 homes and I
thought you give me 1 million dollars
see how much wood I can move across the
country how much land I can restore in
South Dakota it's it's really nothing
one time and four years later we're
still having benefits from the wood and
if you grow grass and you give it four
years to actually star
get up and running then it's Equestria's
carbon that's why people keep saying
grassland sequester carbon once they're
up and running it's getting them up and
running is the key so growing hedgerows
of black locust and populous or what I'm
thinking and then move it out so I'm an
ecologist and for quite a while over in
town we can get a grassland back here
and what they said is listen we have
five times the population United States
we don't worry about feeding them next
year we worry about feeding them
tomorrow this is kind of have to make
food of some kind I'm just telling right
now they'll never have a natural grass
that's like okay but then I think you
have to have grasses you don't want to
irrigate at all I think we can get it to
a grass and not have to and then you
have options you could be perennial
grains Matt Ryan's talking a little bit
about perennial grains and crimping you
can have livestock limited raising if
you put the right ones in by olive feel
in the u.s. switchgrass is being used
which is a native kind of come Berg
Adams a native grass very common and
it's a basis for biofuel production so
you have other grass options if you go
to anything but grasses you get this
little going and jump start where you
can grow crops you're gonna end up it's
gonna degrade again I mean without
having a constant the grass is supplying
the system even the locusts you know it
will start to disappear for them um
apparently China as of late three years
ago was not into biofuels which is
really interesting what they called
first generational biofuels but in
second generation biofuels they're
starting to consider it I think our
group might be able to convince them to
start as a way to get plants out on the
landscape which then support birds and
wildlife and I think it's got a role
panagra gaydom or the comparable species
over there so I want grasses back
honestly
for that but that's 26 water you thought
about the implications water staying
there for a long time and recharging so
for Nick Shaw I mean the Yellow River is
the only source of water and the little
city in the city where and there's 2
million people it's considered almost a
town that's how old people and they are
sucking water out of the river and it
now runs dry in parts and so try the
government says look you can't take that
much you can have this much and so the
alternative is like in India like here
they're switching to ground water people
don't understand ground water and so
they're putting Wells everywhere and
sucking it up and so they don't get how
limited water is there
it's just intriguing to me in theory we
could get grass is growing and this
whole phenomenon condensation how much
more water you might start to build into
the system and and so there's all this
pressure for what are being pulled out
of the system
this would at least maybe buffer some of
that but until there's a more holistic
look of you know about how the world
uses water that's why to me if we can
just reduce irrigation demand with this
we were out there didn't mention it but
the what the Chinese government is doing
in terms of vegetation at least at the
time they have about 2000 people go out
into the desert
it's with these little white straws in
in the mud 1 and square foot baby
then they put one seedling of a desert
grass in there and 2,000 people they
only have about 2 months out of the year
that there's enough water for the
seedling to to even establish itself
probably 60 70 percent of them died
anyway
in the subsequent summer begins to
exceed and maybe they cover with no 2000
people they cover maybe public parish
maybe this is all manual they word of
putting all Weis by straws in just to
make the environment slightly less harsh
reduce the wind erosion so they're
trying-- but I mean you tended a
long-term have that kind of an approach
I mean it's just the labor needs and so
they're kind of keeping that up a little
bit but it's absolutely impossible you
have to have a much more vision it's an
excellent point again it's the recipe
you know what is not there and we
haven't said to you what's the chemistry
of the rainfall maybe you also need to
add these because you're never going to
get it out of the rain
we haven't gotten to that okay for what
it's worth we're just oh it's kind of
like oh the soil health assessment gives
us the diagnostic tool to figure out the
ingredients that are needed you know
that's about where we are and Kirsten
will be you know what we're going to
look at that linkage if that's the right
way we're really feeling our way a
little bit a little bit for how to do
this but that's a good point so it
didn't do a great job and so he was
putting it on at the race of farmers now
have very high electrical conductivity I
don't know where they got I don't know
what happened but we got much lower
growth of the wheat in that less
bacterial development like the info it
didn't help the soil properties as much
it could be the sewage could be a part
of it but my sense of like I'm postman
ores they tend to decompose more quickly
I'm we started this saying leaving these
stuff in you know eight years from now
that stuff's not gone you're not gonna
get the replenish it so we haven't again
it's a recipe maybe that's the right
thing to add to give us a nutrient piece
we need some readily decomposable
material plus some things that are more
slow it could be a good part of it I
know the whole sewage thing
depending on where comes if it's mixed
with industrial ways you have oh then
the heavy metals I mean home hurries
Oh thing you know oh this is not healthy
so we didn't start there we actually
felt we needed microbial inoculants so
Baron I didn't show up but when they
hired actually a geneticist who did an
entire analysis of genetics of the
school microbial communities and there
were all the things you find in our
grasslands are they're at very small
amounts including there's just one
that's unique that's right Ciara
documented native grasslands had this
are dominated by Veruca micro D these is
the name of the group I don't they
dominate in healthy grant native
grasslands they're almost gone and they
were like oh there they are there so we
don't know that we need a microbial
inoculant or a while the soui you know a
compost tea just recommend it could be a
way to bring that in if we need it not
there yet these people become good
friends parents close they're really
great at first there was more language
and I didn't learn Chinese I'm trying to
learn the symbols I work visually some
of the femur looking they spoke it and
they're getting better and better it
definitely affected our ability to
function scientifically we would go once
a year sometimes twice we thought we
communicated things one way we come back
well that's you know it's your distance
and all those things affect but what's
interesting is like this woman's very
influential if we convince them it works
the Chinese government will just do it
it's like okay everybody we're changing
we're doing this that's how now so it's
actually kind of like the Beijing
Olympics they had all this algae show up
where long as sure right before they had
the boating thing they had 10,000 people
go out with buckets and get rid of it I
mean oh we're doing this you know that's
how and so we could actually change a
very big chunk of landscape
works successful it's so issues like we
don't know whether and they're worried
well it's that gonna hurt my crops if
some bugs gonna show up in there now
it's gonna say oh we haven't looked at
that okay in northern North Dakota oh we
go
nobody's gonna do that you know how are
you gonna make them do that they're not
going to do that you even have to
convince them should putting
demonstrations provide subsidies
you know the whole schmear it's totally
it's actually gonna be harder to get it
to happen in the United States you know
that's under underpinning so it's really
interesting there I think we'll make
headway they're buying in here it's
gonna be a slow ebay else yep acting is
just a curiosity so do we think that the
prices are more like competitive in
terms of preventing soil erosion
compared to like our crops and annual
plants or shrubs trees okay I think
we're not I'm I'm not there I'm like
learning prairie grasses you know I'm
not a grass for some oh well well in
specialist anyway so but I there's an
awful lot about grasses that is
conducive to preventing erosion these
networks of roots these deep roots
they're there through the winter
they're definitely using tree planting
as a restoration technique over there
but they're here to gain like crazy and
they don't have that kind of network of
roots a you know for Mossad literally I
don't know enough about the different
species of the grass and so particularly
guys I'm trying to feel what's going on
in the tropical grasslands they probably
don't have these organic soils I think
different grasses that really can handle
dry periods and they go dormant I don't
know I think you're right I think
grasses are evolved more I'm painting
than to both the above-ground structure
and then below ground multiple ways to
deal with not having rainfall but I
agree I think they're probably helping
with the whole erosion
all right thank you this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at Cornell edu